WITH HARRIS FAULKNER AND
KAYLEIGH MCENANY AND TAMMY BRUCE
AND DAVID WEBB.
WE HAVE THE INFLATION CRISIS TO
THE DOORSTEPS OF VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS HERSELF WITH A BUS
LOAD OF MIGRANTS.
DAYS AFTER BORDER HARRIS CALLED
THE BORDER SECURE.
MEANWHILE ANOTHER REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, FLORIDA'S RON DESANTIS
TAKING SIMILAR ACTION SENDING
TWO PLANE LOADS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
YOU KNOW, THAT RITZY VACATION
HOT SPOT FOR WEALTHY LIBERALS.
DEMOCRATS AND THE LIBERAL HAVE
BEEN BLASTING THE MOVES
VILIFYING THE GOVERNORS AS
INHUMANE AND RACIST AND
COMPARING IT TO THE IN, ATZIS.
WATCH.
>> GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S RACIST AND
XENOPHOBIC PRACTICES OF
EXPULSION HAVE ONLY AMPLIFIED
THE CHALLENGES MANY OF THE
MIGRANTS EXPERIENCED ON THEIR
JOURNEY TO FIND A SAFE PLACE.
>> THE CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE IS
ABOUT $80,000 PER BUS TRIP AND
WE KNOW RACISTS DON'T MIND
PAYING THE MONEY.
RACISTS ARE WILLING TO PAY THE
MONEY AND DON'T CARE IFT
TAXPAYERS PAY THE BRUNT.
>> WE WOKE UP TO THE NEWS THISIN
MORNING THAT GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS OF FLORIDA SENT TWO
PLANE LOADS OF MIGRANTS TOAT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OFF THE COASTD
OF MASSACHUSETTS INCLUDING KIDS
AND WHATNOT.
NOT SAYING IN IS NOT A ONE FORT
ONE.DS
NOT A PARALLEL IN ANY WAY BUT
DOES ADDRESS SOME OF THE SAME
THEMES THAT ARE PART OF THE
DOCUMENTARY.
>> Emily: SOME OF THE SAME
THEMES, TAMMY.
TO THE HOLOCAUST?
RACIST AND HUMANE IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD BUT NOT AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
HOW DID THEY COME UP WITH THIS?
>> Tammy: IT'S SHOCK VALUE
MENTIONING THAT AND MOVING
PEOPLE INTO THAT DIE DAM ICK TO
CONFUSE THEM AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS IT'S THIS RHETORIC
ABOUT SANCTUARY CITIES PROVIDING
AN INCENTIVE AROUND THE WORLD
AND THE WORLD SANCTUARY IS
POWERFUL AND THESE INDIVIDUALS
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD, NOT
JUST SOUTH AND CENTRAL AMERICA
HAVE SPENT WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS
IN DANGEROUS, UNKNOWN, CRAZY,
YOU KNOW, THAT DYNAMICS WHERE
CHILDREN ARE ABUSED AND SEX
TRAFFICKING AND WE'VE SEEN A
STORY WHERE WE FOUND TRAFFICKERS
TRANSPORTING PEOPLE IN SUITCASES
AND IN WATER BARRELS.
THESE PEOPLE WHO CREATED THIS
INCENTIVE AND WHO'VE MADE IT
POSSIBLE TO MAKE MONEY LIKE THIS
ON THE BACKS OF HUMAN BEINGS,
THE LITTERING OF THE HUMAN
BODIES THAT WE DON'T SEE ALONG
THIS TRAIL FROM THE MIDDLE EAST,
FROM ASIA, FROM SOUTH AND
CENTRAL AMERICA, CREATING THIS
DYNAMIC WHERE PEOPLE WANT TO GO
TAKE THAT FIRST STEP PAY, ALL
THEIR MONEY TO GET HERE AND THEN
SUDDENLY THE FIRST TIME THEY
HAVE ACTUAL SECURE
TRANSPORTATION TO A CITY OR TO
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT PORTRAYS
ITSELF AS THIS IS THE PLACE TO
COME.
THIS IS WHERE YOU'LL BE SAFE.
AND NOW THEY COMPLAIN AND ARE
CONDEMNED AND IT'S CONSIDERED AN
ASSAULT ON THE CITIES.
WHAT THIS HAS REVEALED IS THE
LIE OF WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID,
THE DANGER THAT THAT RHETORIC
HAS PLACED PEOPLE IN AND WHEN
PEOPLE MAKE IT TO THIS POINT,
THEY CONDEMN THE GOVERNORS FOR
TRYING TO HELP FACILITATE SOME
LEVEL OF SAFETY AND OF COURSE IT
SHOWS YOU THAT THEY'VE NEVER
INTENDED THERE TO BE SANCTUARY
FROM THE FIRST POINT.
IT'S ACTUAL BEEN ABOUT
DISRUPTING THE BORDER AND RED
REPUBLICAN GOP STATES AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN, OF WOMEN WHO REMAIN
ENSLAVED IN THE COUNTRY IN PART
DUE TO HAVING TO PAY BACK THE
MONEY THEY'VE TAKEN TO GET HERE
WITH, YOU KNOW, SOME KIND OF
FORCE.
>> Harris: THEY GOT TO WORK IT
OFF.
>> Tammy: YEAH, IT EXPOSES THE
LIE AND WHAT IT'S DONE TO HUMAN
LIVES.
IT'S SHAMEFUL.
>> Emily: YEAH, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THAT HYPOCRISY FOR A
SECOND BAA YOU'RE POINTING OUT
THAT CONNED SESSION OF THE LEFT,
WE GAVE THEM BEDS AND
HEALTHCARE.
PATTING HIMSELF ON THE BACK FOR
50.
THE VILE CONDITIONS IN EL PASO,
WHICH YOU'VE COVERED
EXTENSIONIVELY ON YOUR SHOW, THE
SMELL OF HUMAN WASTE AND
LITTERING THE STREETS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO SPACE FOR ANYONE,
THAT'S IGNORED.
IT'S THE CRUELTY OF COMPASSION
AND THE JOKE AND MOCKERY THE
DEMS OF THEIR MAKE OF THEIR
VILLAGES AND 4,000 ISN'T OKAY
BUT 50 ARE.
>> Harris: THE DEMOCRAT MAYOR
OF EL PASO PUT PEOPLE ON BUSES.
>> Emily: THERE YOU GO.
>> Harris: THAT WAS A REALITY
HE NO LONGER WANTED TO LIVE
WITH.
HE HAD TO TELL HIS CONSTITUENTS
EYE TO EYE I'M DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
WASHINGTON DC DOESN'T HAVE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T SEE US
AND DON'T NEED TO PROVE IT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THOSE PEOPLE MUST NOT EAT EGGS
BECAUSE OF PRICE OF EGGS IS
RIDICULOUS AND GOING UP HIGHER
AND HIGHER AND AMERICANS ARE
STRUGGLING TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE AND THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
NEED TO EAT TOO AND THEY'LL EAT
UP OUR TAX DOLLARS AND, LOOK, WE
HAVE THE HEART TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE AMERICA.
FILLED WITH AMERICANS.
BUT THESE PLACES AS WILL CAIN
TOLD ME LAST HOUR, THESE PLACES,
THESE SANCTUARY CITIES AND
STATES PUT OUT THE INVITATION OF
COME HERE.
AND TAMMY IS SO RIGHT, THEY LIED
WHEN THEY DID IT.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Harris: NOW THEY HAVE TO
PROVE TO US THEY WEREN'T LYING.
THEY GOT TO TAKE ALL THESE
PEOPLE IN AND NOT ONLY JUST FEED
THEM BUT MAKE THEIR LIVES BETTER
THAN WHEN THEY GOT TO THE
BORDER.
THEY GOT TO PROVE THAT THEY'RE
BETTER THAN REPUBLICANS AT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING?
THE MAYOR OF DC BEGGING FOR
FEDERAL.H I NEED THE NATIONAL
GUARD AND THIS AND THAT.
MEANWHILE, EMILY, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN AT
THE BORDER THAT WE KNOW OF.
CLOSE TO 2 MILLION BY THE END OF
THE FIRST FISCAL YEAR IN BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY.
WOW.
>> Emily: BIDEN'S AMERICA.
I'LL ASK YOU THAT SAME QUESTION,
KAYLEIGH, I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND IT, WHY IS IT VILE AND
INHUMAN FOR THE BORDER MAYORS
AND BORDER GOVERNORS TO HELP
SPREAD OUT AND TRY TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE RESOURCES BEING DILUTED
ON THEIR END AND VILE AND HUMAN
FOR THEM TO SPREAD THE LOVE AND
NOT VILE AND HUMANE TO HAVE THE
POOREST SOUTHERN BORDER OPEN
LIKE A TITLE WAVE TO SUBJECT THE
MIGRANTS TO THE HORRIBLE VILE
SITUATIONS.
>> Kayleigh: WHY IS IT EVIL
AND HUMANE TO SEND MIGRANTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND NOT EVIL
AND HUMANE SENDING PRYOR
GRANTS -- MIGRANTS AROUND THE
NATION.
>> Harris: OF MINORS.
>> Kayleigh: YEAH, EXACTLY.
ONE INTERESTING PIECE OF FOOTAGE
CAME OUT.
GRIFF JENKINS GOES IN FRONT OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S ZELDON I
RESIDENCYASKING IF THE BORDER I.
HIS QUOTE IS ASTONISHLY.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT SAYS IT'S
OWNERSHIP AND CLOSE AND EVERYONE
BELIEVES IT'S OPEN BECAUSE WE'RE
FREE TO ENTER, NO PROBLEM.
WE CAME ILLEGALLY AND NOT
LEGALLY.
THIS IS THE MAKING OF S AND N
SKITS BUT IT'S NOT FUNNY AT ALL
AND STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S HOME SAYING
IT'S IT'S WE'RE AT A BREAKING
POINT AND HE'S SUBJECT TO THE
RESIDENCY REQUIREMENT WHERE
EVERYONE GETS A BED WHO'S
HOMELESS AND NOW HE CAN'T EVEN
KEEP UP.
THE ACTIVISTS ARE ON HIM AND
THIS IS HYPOCRISY AT AN UNTOLD
LEVEL THIS SHIPPING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT, DAVID.
THE STAR CONTRAST AND
APOCALYPTIC EL PASO AND THEN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND THE BED OF
EVERYONE OF THE EIGHT THAT HAVE
COME HERE BECAUSE WE CAN TAKE
CARE OF THEM.
THAT CONDESCENDING HYPOCRITICAL
FASHION.
>> David: HOW ABOUT OUTRIGHT
LIES AND LET'S GO WITH WHAT IT
REALLY IS.
STARTING WITH EVERYTHING FROM
TAMMY TO WHAT YOU'VE ALL SAID
ABOUT THIS.
THEY WANT TO CALL DESANTIS FOR
AVID RACIST FOR SENDING ILLEGAL
ALIENS AROUND THE COUNTRY, WELL
BIDEN'S BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS
SO HE'S THE RACEST.
RACIST.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT AND I
TRAVEL AROUND AND DO THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY CARE AND DO THEY
ACTUALLY TRY AND SHIFT THE
NARRATIVE?
THINK JUST OUTRIGHT LIE AND IN
THE END, WHAT'S THE AGENDA?
YOU CREATE A PROBLEM THAT'S TOO
BIG TO FIX.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID WITH CHUCK
TODD LAST SUNDAY TALKING ABOUT
AMNESTY AGAIN AND THEY'RE NOT
SPEAKING ABOUT ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND TALKING TO THE PEOPLE THAT
WILL VOTE DEMOCRATS AND RISK
LOSING THE HOUSE AND LOSING IN
THE STATES AND THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN ON BY OTHER DEMOCRATS AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE'RE THE
BIGGEST CONSTITUENCY AND THE
PERSON PEOPLE SEE US AND WE'RE
BUILDING FENCES IN ZUCKERBERG UN
TO PROTECT THEIR BOARDERS AND
NOT PROTECTING OUR OWN.
WE CAN'T AFFORD THIS AND IT GOES
ON THROUGH THE LIFE OF THE
ILLEGAL ALIEN WHEN RESOURCES,
COUNTY RESOURCES, STATE
RESOURCES, ALL TAXPAYER
RESOURCES ARE USED TO HELP THAT
LIFE EXIST.
>> Harris: FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAD IDEAS ON HOW TO DEAL
WITH IT.
IT'S NOT ALL ON THE DEMOCRATS
WHO DIDN'T HELP HIM GET THAT
DONE.
THERE WERE REPUBLICANS WHO
DIDN'T HELP HIM GET THAT DONE.
>> David: VERY TRUE.
>> Emily: HE IMPLEMENTED THEM